Hello
bitches.
Do you know the story of the salt and the Dubai assaulting to Brunei?
Rather saw no Brunei.
Um,
he would bring in gals and pay them like $50,000 a month.
Just come on down and they would go for a few months,
make quarter million bucks,
then fly home and then they'd get all this jewelry and diamonds and shit and one
little hook or ruin the whole Party.
Buy Shoes.
They caught it with a laptop,
just writing stories about it.
She wanted to write a book about her experience.
So this dude,
this is what he would do.
He had a disco in his house and one of his many houses and a,
he would have it filled with all these girls who are making,
who knows how much money,
just tens of thousands of dollars.
And he would come out and he's fucking gold underwear and just in slippers and
slide across the room.
Like he was in that scene with Tom Cruise.
What's that movie?
Risky business play slides in.
He'd slide in like that and as gold underwear and just go eenie Meenie meiny
mountain.
Just pick one out
and just fuck oh shit out of them.
And then the next day do the same thing and he'd do whatever he wants and that
chick wrote the story on it.
One of them did.
Wow.
Yeah,
and he was like,
so what
is that?
Had I known?
That's really him.
That's him.
Like pack Reagan.
It Vinny meanie meiny mode.
That guy's totally covered in gold.
Look at them.
If that guy's worth more money than you can ever,
can I be one of these girls?
Oh my God.
Go Away for 50,000 I'm doing a Gig in Dubai guys for a whole month.
You just want to be the court jester.
Go over there and crack some jokes,
man.
That's fucking crazy.
And you think he wears a condom?
No.
No condom.
Right?
Shut up.
Why would he do that?
Yeah,
exactly.
He's just shooting loads of these gals,
but then again,
he's opening himself up for possible.
I wonder if,
to what I bet he gets them tested.
He puts him in catapults and shoots him in the air.
I am closer to being Lance Armstrong,
like closest on a diet to absent all carbohydrates,
but I'm still,
you know,
now I'm just a bigger individual.
I mean,
it's interesting.
We were talking about,
uh,
you know,
I was talking to,
a friend of mine was at freshmen manager of my college football team.
So this was Harvard.
Okay.
It was division two football.
He was a lot of smart,
you know,
guys who couldn't make it in division one.
We had kids who went to Harvard because they didn't get scholarships at Holy
Cross.
So they went,
okay,
I'll play football for Harvard.
They were local.
1976 my senior year,
the biggest kid on our team,
Danny tickets,
weight 265 pounds,
six foot five from our standards.
He was enormous.
He went off to play for the Chicago bears for five or six years.
I think we had one other offensive lineman who was two 65 also six,
four,
six,
five,
um,
maybe two this year.
Harvard football team,
smart kid,
same socioeconomic status.
The entire office of,
they got I think 12 players over 300 pounds to his.
These guys were enormous.
I mean there's six seven 300 pounds.
They didn't grow people that big when I was growing up.
I mean I could say maybe I didn't see him,
maybe they weren't around.
Maybe they were six seven and they only weighed two 30 cause they weren't being
bulked up so they were playing basketball instead of football.
I mean I could imagine ways that that confusing but from our perception if you
look just what happens when I was a kid in early 1960s I remember I as far as I
know there was one 300 pounder in the NFL and the AFL,
two different leads back then.
Bob De,
I remember his name,
he played for the Boston Patriots and his head was like small compared to his
body and he was a big fat guy.
You know what is there now 2030 per team
and you're saying like a lot of people are saying no the sciences out because
their spend billions of dollars to do that.
The thing is,
is when you are playing such far right,
far left partisan politics.
Yeah.
Then you have people saying,
Oh,
uh,
Obamacare,
he's a socialist.
He's trying to take over the government.
He's trying to do this,
he's trying to do that and sort of blowing it out.
Why?
Because that creates the tea party,
which you know,
comes in and then they have power and then the tea party by the way,
has to go back to their constituents and say,
we're going to repeal it.
We're going to do this,
we're going to do anything.
And it just becomes,
everything goes to the atomic level.
And so that when you actually go into,
into,
you know,
into Congress or the executive or into the Senate and you try to get anything
done,
you can't because you've promised that you're not going to do anything.
You're going to have any sort of,
you know,
partisan,
uh,
you know,
relation,
bipartisan,
bipartisan
relations.
Yeah.
It's fucked up man.
It's,
and it's stupid.
And it exists because we have two parties.
When you make to people we make,
one of them were red and you make one of them were blue,
they start wanting to fight each other.
It's a,
it's a stupid thing are also disagree.
You're also,
it doesn't matter if you're in or out,
you're always empower cause there's only two,
right.
So you're always going to be,
this is the sort of opposition.
Yeah.
And that influenced the problem is like this is what people have to realize.
A lot of your opinions and my opinions too,
I'm not really my opinions,
their opinions that I have decided are good that I've heard from other people.
Right.
And a lot of our patterns of behaviors from accents to the way we approach
culture,
that the way we think about women,
the way we think about religion,
a lot of that is learned.
Okay.
And we have these two deeply ingrained patterns in this country.
We have the Democrats and we have the Republicans and the Republicans are these
no nonsense get business done.
You know,
and the,
the Democrats are,
you know,
we always think of all these people are all cry babies and they're all wishy
washy and they're bleeding hearts.
And,
and that this is like ingrained,
it's sort of ingrained in our system,
these two different
patterns of behavior if they're severely problematic because you could exhibit a
lot of traits on each sides and still be a very good person or a lot of ideas on
each side and still be a very good person.
Cause here's the awful thing about being an adult in a relationship to seeking
to be an adult in a relationship.
I have found,
uh,
when I was young and I was a boy and I was dating girls,
it's poison girls and she's an idiot.
You're an idiot and you do dumb things.
And if when cheats and whatever,
then you hit a certain part of your life where she's a woman and you're a man
and you have adult expectations and you can't be running around being an idiot
with someone who kind of wants you to be at the table because they are sincerely
giving time of their adult life to this thing that you were doing together.
And when you come in still thinking you're in ninth grade and she's coming in
like this is part of what my life is,
is being with you.
I have never been able to answer that in a mature enough way to where I would
have been able to maintain it.
Because like say next weekend if I had a girlfriend,
she might say it's Friday.
What are we doing?
I'm like,
oh,
watching me write for four hours
worse.
And so that's not the way to be.
You can't do that.
And so I can't be a good persons other half cause I'm always,
the work has always attracted me more than coming home to someone.
Wow.
Like,
I,
I can't stand the idea of someone of living with a person.
I can do it on the bus cause it's das boat and we're like,
you know,
going down the road.
Um,
but I,
I never would want to like wake up and she's there
and I have no aversion.
Right.
She's there
every day.
Here we are together and I'm just not wired that way.
Oh,
by the way,
did you see that,
uh,
that little clip that was making its way around at the inauguration on the
inauguration stand of Bill Clinton checking out and getting caught.
That was nice.
Ivanka and Ivanka,
his daughter so hot.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
God,
Jesus Christ.
Those jeans look was fantastic.
The look was pure Bill Clinton.
He,
well,
he was like,
fuck it.
It's over.
I don't have to hold it back anymore.
Look at it.
I'll let me look it up.
Oh,
good Lord.
He's shaking.
He's licking his light.
When she turns around and looks at them,
look at that.
Oh my goodness.
And then he looks,
it gives her a quick look.
Yeah.
Once he looks at her,
he's like,
listen,
bitch,
you know who I am.
You know you live with a wolf.
They'll get dad out.
You know you live in a big old gray wolf.
She's,
hi everyone.
I'm Ivanka Trump.
Want to remind?
I wish you had a fucking accent.
What's going on there?
Oh,
it's her giving him a massage.
this is like a porn film that they did a fake porn about Ivanka Trump.
Look beautiful.
It's the best part of the inauguration day.
It's over.
I can beat me again.
I'm tired of it all.
That would be the only reason I wanted,
or I would have wanted a Hillary Clinton when the only bright spot,
I guess I should say instead,
the only bright spot to her wedding would have been that he would have been back
in and the house.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
As a first mom man on a rampage,
he'd probably be on a rampage.
Watches.
Watch his mouth.
Yeah.
I love little bites.
His lower lip.
He says like miles Ivanka.
No,
he doesn't.
What can we say this?
Oh,
oh,
Ivanka.
Oh yeah,
yeah.